the first rain in months has bought them
some time but the fires are still plenty
and still far too strong one of the
biggest is the timber factory in Eden
it's been the bedrock of much of the
town's employment for years losing it is
seen as a collective tragedy they are
working hard to try and save as much of
this industry as possible forestry is an
industry that they rely on here losing
this Factory is going to have a
catastrophic economic impact on the
whole of the area and that's why they're
trying to save as much of these logs as
possible but they are in the teeth of a
crisis right now and the little rain
they're getting is nowhere near enough
[Music]
that will take significant amount of
buying
[Music]
clapping zeroes
these firefighters are making sacrifices
on a daily basis and none more so than
the family of Nathan bonden his uncle
and cousin both died trying to save
their home but still he's on the
bushfire frontlines we went with the
volunteer as he traveled around the
Baker Valley assessing the most recent
damage his family hasn't even had the
funerals yet doing his bit for the
community seems to be what's getting him
through this all we can help others not
go through what our family is going
through and that's why I've put the
uniform back on everyday and that's why
my dad does and my brother does and why
we keep going because if we can make
sure that no one else has to feel what
my family and what my auntie and the
rest of our family are feeling then
they're not done my job and that's
that's all I can ask those in the
control room
are trying to stop two huge fires in
Victoria and New South Wales from
meeting and forming one mega blaze which
would engulf hundreds of thousands of
hectares they know higher temperatures
are on the way again in days and it's
far from over
they've got to that size now we're
hanging out for significant rain we
could be talking several weeks or months
that almost certainly means more of this
flattened buildings a fractured
infrastructure and a charred landscape
which is going to take years to recover
hundreds have spent the past few nights
sheltering on boats at Eaton Wharf once
strangers there now firm friends there's
much dispute - over what's led to this
crisis
just fair enough we are in a drought
caused by climate change that
Australia's away and the droughts it
floods it it has to be done in a proper
way and people's lives there won't be
lost the answers to who or what is
responsible for this disaster will
follow they're still coping here with
unprecedented loss the shoreline of Eden
is now choked with ash all life here is
taking strain and the scale of the
events here have raised alarm across the
world
Alex Crawford Sky News in New South
Wales Australia